I think today's topic is most serious
and stupid Amigos which is a Welly
really well well renowned rap group and
so the three guys they rap they feature
on a lot of songs they're very popular
in the hip-hop scene and two of them
quavon takeoff were both at a uh pool
hall of sorts after hours what ended up
happening was that one of them was
killed so I'm gonna play the video of
the news report and I'm going to give
you the details that was come to light
if you're somebody who leaked the
details uh a text exchange they had
pictures of proof that they were
actually at the event John thank you we
moved to National headlines for you this
morning at 7 20 a developing story out
of Houston Texas TMZ is reporting rapper
takeoff a member of Migos is dead the 28
year old is reportedly shot at a bowling
alley in Houston at around 2 30 this
morning TMZ says takeoff was there with
cuevo another member of Migos sources
say someone started shooting after a
fight broke out so the story goes like
this according to the text message when
I put the screenshot up on screen
was apparently losing getting mouthy
with somebody was getting heated and
according to eyewitnesses
as things were getting heated and people
are starting to spout off
after quavo said something one of the
guys behind quavo people who were part
of the Entourage pulled out a gun and
started firing and then from the other
group other shots started fighting and
once the initial gunshots went off
takeoff who is cuevo's uh cousin cousin
and part of the Migos he immediately
fell to the floor so it comes to light
that before the opposition even started
firing he went down which means what it
was most likely Friendly Fire meaning
his mans is the one who probably put the
bullet in him into his neck now that's a
quarter Thai Witnesses so story may
change after more details comes out uh
but that's according to think
he was pronounced dead at the scene
which means he had nothing left
apparently bullet hit his artery and if
you know anything about neck wounds
they're pretty much always fatal uh it's
very difficult to come back from a neck
when it means being just splits like
crazy so this has got so many layers
um first off this is an unfortunate
unnecessary Death let's just start there
you can do this whole entire breakdown
you can break down the gun aspect of it
you can break down this aspect of its
safety friends fire friendly you
you know the truth is this is just
[ __ ] sad and unfortunate and it's
just like how many more people do we
have to lose to unnecessary [ __ ] be
it like people with core morbidity and
obesity issues people with like stupid
gun violence over [ __ ] people over
just dumb fights at the club over some
ego [ __ ] like it's just so [ __ ]
annoying and sad to know that we lose
people who could be in their communities
contributing could be doing stuff could
have the potential to do things in the
future or whatever it is and and you
just lose folks
you lose folks if you don't lose the
people involved like turns out takeoff
the one who died wasn't even part of the
disputeful he was really quiet in the
corner he just happened to catch the
stray bullet and that's what happens
it's like sometimes when you hang around
people who don't know how to use their
head it's the wrong person who ends up
taking the bullet Ah that's just I read
this and I'm not a fan of the Migos I'm
not I don't follow this right I don't
care it's not that it's just like
it's senseless it's unnecessary it's
very unnecessary and that's what
happened
when something is happening it's tragic
it's one thing
it's one thing that happens that is
tragic [ __ ] happens all the time that is
tragic well his Miss really wanted could
all this [ __ ] could have been avoided
that that's what hits me
close but you know the person you don't
know the person well it hits is when it
could have been avoided over dumb [ __ ]
really you know I mean
and some [ __ ] that we kind of do to
ourselves it's like
we do to ourselves and everybody every
time every time that someone always talk
about their community and talking to the
community be like there's some stupid
[ __ ] that we do and we're known for that
[ __ ] and it happens too much and then
you're cast as a whoa you ain't real
[ __ ] you ain't doing this you want that
you just the same negativity but it's
negative
it's not good
and you know what happens it happens all
the time
and the best way that the person that I
don't know described it was Aaron
Magruder
in The Boondocks
[ __ ] moment
that's exactly what it is and the worst
thing is not the worst thing with one of
the funniest [ __ ] up things is that
we were talking about it before it
happened
right there in the living room talking
about what makes it that this [ __ ]
happened and this and that and then look
boom again
again
a scuffle that started because you was
losing over dice
but you know it's not about the dice
it's about the ego it's about the ego
they rolling they lose that's not the
problem they can start talking [ __ ]
somebody don't like a little quib that
someone gave them and you'll watch how
your man's just talking
and then she'll pop off you go ego
that's all this is it's not someone
stole somebody's money something like
that it's ego
this is why I tell people like your
pride is oftentimes a really useless and
counterproductive emotion it's like
folks saying it's not your pride you're
just full of ego you don't know how to
walk away from something
you don't know how to not push up like
just let it go let that [ __ ] go
because you save yourself a lot of
Heartache oh you look like you alive you
better be alive than to die over dumb
[ __ ] this is stupid this is a dumb
reason to pick a fight and to act hard
with somebody
but that's what we encourage don't let
nobody you think you're getting punked
just because you didn't want to go back
and forth with somebody over a [ __ ]
dice
especially in a country like America
where everyone's packing and carrying
especially at that place at that time of
night with those kind of people when you
know people are definitely packing it's
stupid and to know that the person who
was okay I don't know if this man was
security or just Entourage
be security stop hiring your best friend
okay stop hiring your homie
cause if them [ __ ] don't have
training with guns they're not there to
protect you they're a liability and they
will get you in danger do you know how
many times police officers who are
trained get caught in crossfire you
actually can see police videos where
they're abandoning all their training
for no reason because they're scared or
they're hyped up in the moment and they
surround the Target and they're
literally across from each other with a
Target in the middle and they start
firing they end up hitting each other
that happens often
now imagine untrained people and how
very likely are to just spray anywhere
well that's what this guy did who you
carry yourself with you know I mean who
you spend time with that'll reflect on
you you know I mean keeping the wrong
friends around get you in bad situations
but this
you know you can give people all the
tips in the world and there's plenty of
stuff you can do preventatively to not
be in that situation to begin with
absolutely but this didn't have to go
there
this didn't have to go there
so that's the unfortunate part
anything else going on
not that we ever already said you know
buff everyone
he's sharing those clips on Twitter of
his body laying there blood gushing
one thing that's also really bizarre
that is The New Normal thank God I'm
gonna put it then yo listen sooner
you'll find all kinds of gory stuff let
me tell you
that is the new normal and I don't think
I'll ever get used to it but the idea
that you out here are bleeding out and
somebody just recording it and then the
next thought is like man this should go
on Twitter or Worldstar this should be
posted my like this man is clearly dying
and you filming and ready to upload it
for some likes like there's something
ecologically sick there you hear me
Park you literally see the amusement and
like the thing breaks and the dude slips
out of the seat from like way up and you
hear him go Splat it's not even that
someone was recording is that thing
uploaded it that's
I'll just I don't know
I don't think it is not entirely
I think this focus on self this ego
driven world
that's an Evidence of that that's what I
think I think with social media with the
whole me me get likes get likes
everything's about that
that [ __ ] and the other [ __ ] aren't that
different that's why how many dudes
being killing each other over social
media posts what did you say there was a
dude who said check my gangster y'all
know where it is I'll be at this address
in 12 10 minutes come find me a drill
artist 10 minutes later this man's there
his Ops go in and they murk him social
media ego and likes
you know what I'm trying to say like
this stuff is all linked
there is a sickness
in this society when it comes to a lot
of this stuff so imagine you get into
like a severe accident and if you've
ever seen a car accident
a serious one it ain't pretty
if you never like um seen limbs or
anything like that
a queasy stomach and a pretty now
imagine that's you in there
and the way that your mom finds out that
you Dead is on social media with your
body parts all sewn apart
your family member that's how they
discover you and the reason why they
discover you that way in that traumatic
fashion their their child their sibling
their whatever pieces
because somebody posted it for likes
that's sickening to me
that's why I don't click on those videos
anymore I don't watch I can't like it's
just
super weird to
to think that's normal now and I don't
think I could ever get a new set so
yeah anything else um
you over it
go ahead yeah I'm over it it's dumb [ __ ]
dump [ __ ] over and over again it's like
it's just when it could have been
avoided that's ugh
what are you trying to say about black
people
you could do better
we definitely could do better there's a
lot of [ __ ] out there that we keep on
doing we keep on doing the thing about
this is that
I think at our job
on Earth
is to bring the cycle into bad cycles
and the bad things that you know that to
your parents or your grandparents or you
know the generational trauma
has been best thrown onto US your job
you being here
you were being here now
you watching all this your job
is to break that
and we ain't breaking [ __ ] [ __ ]
I'm talking so still still feels like
we're stuck in the slave days
and it's always these against us and
house [ __ ] it's like versus field
[ __ ] and that's how we view life
it's very let's still go back to slavery
and [ __ ]
if it's not slavery it's colonism
where they set us apart we don't see we
have to break that [ __ ] we have to
break that cycle we have to the guns and
[ __ ] like that
that's a reversible
there's nothing you could do about that
and again it's Pride
maybe it's because I miss the good old
days
I miss that
I missed that with
yo when we had a problem we had a
problem be like yo it's me and you let's
go and if you agreed onto that it was
you and you and that person
and after that you gotta
you shook hands
and you let that [ __ ] behind
and there was rules to it too
you can't hit a [ __ ] if he's on
the ground yo let him back up let him
back up let him back up all right you
ready let's go I'm not saying that
that's better [ __ ] that it is better
it is better it is better [ __ ] that you
know what man
and I'm not even trying to tell you that
though oh yeah but it's violence yeah
you know sometimes the aggression needs
to get out
if you want to settle some [ __ ] let's go
if you can't settle it and we need to
break this [ __ ] we need to break this
[ __ ] cycle
man one of my earliest childhood
memories was me and this other kid were
beefing
and I remember my brother and a bunch of
the older kids around the neighborhood
got us to the park or away from where
the parents and all the families were
they made a circle they said duke it out
duke it out hey what I know how this is
a true story because I lost the fight
what kind of [ __ ] could make up a story
about him losing a fight hey you want to
know how I lost it I never forget this
is like one of my early childhood
memories I remember you hit me right in
the stomach that's the first time I ever
couldn't breathe you know when the gut
punches right here right in the middle
where all of a sudden he was not ready
yeah I was doing that [ __ ]
but I remember just the image of just
people surrounding us in a circle that
we just handled at that right and I
think from that point on that was always
normal but I remember maybe I was 19
this is when I started noticing a bit of
a shift but you started hearing about
dudes at the club getting juked all the
time right just somebody going to the
car coming back yeah right and that
became normal and I'm sorry I have to
watch out for dudes for the way that
they were standing what they were
carrying and then you started learning
about the universal code oh he's going
back to his car everybody Deuces yeah
because we know dip we know right if
they reach it into a bag then you start
learning these new signals it's no
longer like
that's done with you can't do it and
these young cats the way their music is
set up everything is get the blicky yeah
everything is get to go this new wave is
a different thing
everything is everybody gets strapped up
we're not doing no fair fights we're not
doing no fights
everything is not going straight to God
yeah and that's the thing that's the
thing is it's different and it comes out
to to to well to Ego like you said
learn how to take a l
it's life
you're gonna take else
but the society right now when the
people in the generation right now when
they take they dare not they were not
allowed to take yes you will take else
it's gonna happen girls Gonna Give You
Wheels
man Gonna Give You L's everybody Gonna
Give You else it's fine
learn to take a [ __ ] hell it it
hurts eat that
eat that and learn from it
eat that she learned from it that's the
best [ __ ] lesson You're Gonna Get You
don't want to eat that [ __ ] no more
start thinking about how can I move
accordingly so I don't eat that L again
I just
learn to take a l some of y'all want to
have kids you guys don't think about
living life in a way that you want your
children to model
do you want to your kid to see that when
you feel disrespected the first thing
you do is get a gun you shoot somebody
in a risk prison time there's no way I
know most of you watching I don't care
if you're part of that life or not the
last thing you want to do is see your
child respond to a bad situation get it
and start shooting right away and go to
jail
but none of you [ __ ] want to
live let me rephrase some of you
[ __ ] don't want to live the way
that you want your children to live
set that example
look you said something today in that
kind of yeah stuff you heard but it's
just interesting
he said uh
the key Stanfield says on Instagram
if you are for gangster rap or this
drill [ __ ] you aren't for black people
I think it's time to start having
conversations
yeah and the way the iteration of it
today and it's one-dimensionalness
is influencing these people
because
yeah I don't know I don't know maybe
this is the wrong track I haven't
thought this one through so I won't
speak on it anymore anything else you
want to say I agree with nothing Keith
all right let us know what you guys
think